nous sommes à bord de la voiture
patrouille des agentes amanda steed et
sandra garofalo elles font partie de la
police pour transport du grand vancouver
d'une organisation créée dans l'unique
but d'assurer la sécurité des usagers du
skytrain et cela jour et nuit
so donc amène stéphane
potentiellement quelqu'un de suicidaire
l'individu a été repéré par les préposés
du centre de surveillance vidéo du
skytrain de leur position ils peuvent
guider les deux policières sur le
terrain le succès de leurs interventions
d'urgence dépend de la rapidité avec
laquelle elles atteindront les lieux
surtout lorsqu'il est question de sauver
une vie sur une infrastructure
électrifié en mouvement sur la
plateforme un homme qui était au niveau
de l'ascenseur et qui en fait se pencher
dangereusement dieu vis-à-vis des rails
donc c'est possible
possiblement jumper on y peut être
quelqu'un de suicidaire qui est qui va
sauter sur sur les rails en 2021 la
police du transport de vancouver est
sous intervenir pour des dizaines
d'appels d'urgence en raison des
civilités et d'infraction au code
criminel
depuis la première pelletée de terre
dure m les services de police impliqués
dans le projet redoutent que cette
réalité se transporte dans le grand
montréal on estime déjà que ce nouveau
métro aérien pourrait accueillir jusqu'à
150 mille passagers à chaque jour lors
de la première année d'entrée en service
visiblement est satisfait que plan
d'intervention ont été conçus sans leur
implication cette direction de police
ont jugé bon d interpeller cdpq infra et
ses partenaires en décembre 2020 on
demande à jean-marc arbaud grand patron
de la filiale infrastructures de la
caisse de dépôt de prendre plus au
sérieux la sécurité les futurs usagers
la police a perdu patience de ne pas
avoir d'interlocuteur ayant un statut
décisionnel pour se pencher sur les
problèmes urgents de sécurité du public
les échanges aujourd'hui sont en place
le dialogue est amorcé et ça se fait de
façon très très bonne de part et d'autre
ce n'est pourtant que la fin du
printemps dernier soit plus d'un an et
demi après le cri d'alarmé des services
de police que le processus pour former
une équipe d'inspecteurs a été lancé les
équipes de certainement vers un bon
nombre de pouvoirs liés au règlement
durable mais face à la criminalité déjà
connu dans le métro de montréal ce
consultant doutent de la capacité des
inspecteurs à répondre de la tâche faut
suivre personne d'autre c'est pour ça
que ça va pas quelque part autres que
des constables spéciaux des inspecteurs
on parle d'un service de police ou un
service spécial pour commencer des
places sur cette bonne criminalité à
trois mois de l'entrée en service de
l'antenne rive-sud du rem cdpq est franc
n'a pas de projections en matière de
criminalité j'userai cadence à ce niveau
là c'est vraiment les services policiers
les services d'un syndic mais ces
réseaux sont évidemment est à vie dans
des municipalités des secteurs d'où la
collaboration qui est important de part
et d'autre is it un élément clé sur
lequel on travaille et c'est encore
présentement
dans un contexte de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre le recrutement aurait dû
débuter bien avant le printemps compte
tenu de l'entrée en service prévue dans
quatre mois au moma qui est pondéré dans
la foi ça touche tout le monde
dépendamment les offres qui va avoir le
puits les conditions ça sera pas évident
de trouver du personnel l'intérêt de
tous surtout si c'est du 24 7 une chose
est certaine les constables spéciaux de
la stm et les policiers de la section
métro du spvm n'ont pas chômé depuis le
début de l'année dans les six premiers
mois de 2000 22 ils ont dû intervenir
pour près de mille infractions au code
criminel dans les stations du métro de
montréal à vancouver translink le
propriétaire du skytrain n'a pas eu
espère tirer l'oreille pour renforcer la
sécurité de ses usagers c'est lui-même
en 2004 qui a fait les démarches
nécessaires pour que son agence de
constables spéciaux deviennent l'année
suivante un corps policier
le chef affirme que ce changement est
venu soulager les 22 municipalités
desservies par le skytrain où différents
services de police ont juridiction en
2021 ils ont répondu à plusieurs appels
pour des infractions au code criminel
qui aurait largement dépassé les
pouvoirs d'un constable spécial
nous avons visité le quartier général de
la police du transport du grand
vancouver depuis que l'équipe de
constables spéciaux a été aboli à 17 ans
le budget du service de police a été
augmentée pour favoriser l' embauche
aujourd'hui la police du transport
regroupe 200 agents une centrale
d'urgence 9-1-1 une section des enquêtes
et depuis les jeux olympiques de
vancouver en 2010 une escouade canine
le sergent responsable de l'unité
rappelle que les infrastructures liées
au transport collectif sont les
premières cibles pour des attentats
terroristes avec la situation mondiale
actuelle le sergent affirme que le
canada n'a pas que des alliés à travers
le monde oui d'autant de respect ils
expliquent beaucoup de colis sont
fréquemment vérifié par l'escouade
canine entraîné pour détecter la poudre
explosive
pour l'agente sandra garofalo qui a vécu
à montréal avant de joindre les rangs de
la police du transport
les appréhensions des services de police
du grand montréal sont fondées je force
que la crimée d'un mois les
tropiques est celle de vancouver parce
qu'on a des personnes armées partout
elle ne croit pas qu'un civil malgré son
statut d'inspecteur pourra intervenir
lors de la commission d'un crime dans
leur haine
ses parents d'une agression en cours la
personne aujourd'hui nous nous proposons
train de noix en aucun cas intervenir
s'ils n'ont pas la formation que les
policiers reçoivent l'utilisation de la
force c'est tout se passe comme prévu le
premier tronçon de l'antenne rive-sud du
rem devrait entrer en fonction le 1er
décembre prochain